today on the matt wall show confirming
our long-standing suspicions superman
has come out as gay yet another iconic
character has been inducted into the
lgbt community we're told that this is
all about creating greater
representation for supposedly
marginalized groups but i think there's
something else going on and i'll explain
also parents at loudoun county call for
the superintendent to resign
after the school district cover up the
rape of a girl in a school bathroom
we'll talk more about that very
important story today and the chicago
police department is having trouble
recruiting new cops big crisis in the
city i wonder why that's happening plus
lego commits itself to combating gender
stereotypes which is a very important
thing we'll talk about that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
in our culture's never-ending quest to
turn literally everything gay it was
only a matter of time before it set its
eyes on superman
as the many celebratory news articles
inform us dc comic writer tom taylor has
just written and will soon release a new
superman comic wherein the iconic
superhero will find himself in a gay
relationship with a male pink-haired
journalist
and this is actually if you look at it
one way a pretty conservative move by dc
i figured that by now we you know would
have a superman
who's non-binary
rename him super them but instead of
super they will have to settle for super
gay i suppose cnn has uh more on this
breaking story it says quote in an
upcoming issue of a new superman series
the man of steel enters into a queer
relationship
the fifth issue of the dc comics
series superman son of kal-el
will confirm that the new superman john
kent child of clark canton lane is
bisexual after falling for jay nakamura
a male reporter
the superman son of kyle series follows
kent as he becomes earth's new superman
and grapples with the immense weight of
his new gig nakamura a bespectacled
writer with a bubblegum pink mop first
appeared in the series third issue as a
shoulder for kent to lean on when the
business of being superman got too rough
but in the forthcoming fifth issue kent
falls for the journalist after he quote
mentally and physically burns out from
trying to save everyone that he can
according to
dc
the particulars of this issue's plot are
to be revealed in november but images
from the comic show uh kent to nakamura
sharing a kiss and sitting together atop
a building their legs dangling off the
edge
so superman also has anxiety issues on
top of it
and this move comes just months after
robin over in gotham city came out as
gay as well not a huge shock there
admittedly the dc universe also features
a lesbian bat woman and various other
members of the lgbt community who have
been shoehorned into
various comic story lines pretty soon
you know the justice league will be the
alphabet league i guess and of course
the the superheroes of this new
generation they don't just show off
their woke credentials through their
homosexual encounters they also are
focused on fighting a different kind of
villain so here's tom taylor the guy who
came up with gay superman
on cnn talking about the sorts of issues
that superman will be involved in now
listen and it struck me as it would be a
real opportunity lost if we had another
we had clark kent
replaced by another straight white
savior so
here was an opportunity to create a
superman who could represent a whole new
group of people and i think that was one
that we had to leave them and we'll be
addressing
modern day issues like
like the climate crisis like refugees um
john in the last issue has just been
arrested attending a protest trying to
stop the refoulement of asylum seekers
um he
does 45 minutes of hard time is how he
puts it
but as a as a stand it's a very powerful
thing
and yes so this is one of the things for
him he is trying to work out who he is
who he is as superman who he is as john
kemp
and so us as the writer and everybody at
dc comics is watching him go through
this process of finding himself and
seeing that on the page
okay so this is a gay environmentalist
superman
i think the creators of captain planet
should really sue for plagiarism if you
ask me i i do wonder how superman will
fight climate change exactly will he
like beat up the sun maybe engage in
hand-to-hand combat with the weather
drop kick a cloud i mean how does that
work exactly and the thing is that would
be exciting to watch of a little bit
confusing i suppose but it sounds like
tom taylor has more earthbound ideas in
mind like having superman attend
political demonstrations you know kids
can now flip excitedly through the pages
of their favorite comic book watching
superman um hold signs and shout slogans
and then go home and start a hashtag
campaign to raise awareness his
kryptonite is a frowny face emoji in the
in the final climactic battle
he defeats lex luthor by uh reporting
him to twitter for hate speech i guess
that's the way it's gonna go
now
you know it's it's easy to make fun of
this kind of thing we should make fun of
it
but
we shouldn't let the fantastic absurdity
distract us from the underlying agenda
which is more sinister than anything gay
superman will be fighting against in the
new comics
we can all look around
and clearly see
that gay and trans characters and story
lines are being injected into everything
from comics to movies to tv shows even
the most
iconic and enduring characters are
forced to undergo this kind of
conversion therapy and we know that the
conversion is only ever allowed to go
one way right white straight characters
can be made non-white or non-straight
but if non-white non-straight characters
are made white or straight it's a hate
crime and everybody responsible must be
fired and then dragged into the town
square and stoned to death that's the
way it works now
but we're told this is this is all a
matter of representation right
the left says that all these identities
must be rammed into every story
because audience members who share that
identity
deserve to be represented tom taylor
made this claim in that same cnn
interview let's listen to that
i promise he will punch a robot that's
just a guaranteed he will come up
against lex luthor in our upcoming
annual um all those things are part and
parcel of superman and this is just
something extra that that very important
symbol can now represent and i have to
say
having seen the reaction today having
seen online what it's meant to people
i've i've seen so many messages from all
over the world in so many different
languages
people saying that they saw this news
and burst into tears people saying that
they never thought that they would be
able to see themselves in superman that
they wish other people who older people
all the queer people have said they wish
they had this growing up and they're so
happy
that younger people or people who
haven't come out yet have this today
that by the way keep this in mind this
kind of thing in mind
um
because
the other thing that we we hear from the
left and i'll i'll probably get this too
because i'm doing this segment right now
when uh some of this inevitably ends up
on media matters
but their concern it's
conservative media making a big deal
about uh bisexual superman isn't that so
ridiculous why do you care so much right
they they do that whole thing
meanwhile
cnn
is doing a news segment on it bringing
the creator of gay superman on to come
on and talk about how people are are
reduced to tears of joy over the fact
that there's a bisexual superman
so
they can make a big deal they make a big
deal about it
on the left and tell us that it's a big
deal i mean it's breaking news we're
talking about it on cnn people are
crying tears of joy they're overcome
with uh with uh you know
feelings of ecstatic
um emotions
because of it that's how big of a deal
it is
but if you say
all right
um fine it's a big deal
i agree it's it's it's socially
culturally relevant
but i have an issue with it i have a
criticism and here it is the moment you
do that then they say what are you
making a big deal of it for
well you're the one who told us it's a
big deal
we're taking you at your word on that
now
if this was all true that this is really
about representation it would only be
more evidence of the increasing
narcissism of our age i mean the whole
idea that we we must be represented in a
story in order in order to connect with
it or understand it
is fundamentally self-centered part of
the beauty of storytelling what we love
about a good story or should love about
it is that we can become absorbed in it
and forget about ourselves to some
extent that's what people mean when they
talk about escapist entertainment and
all entertainment is or should be
escapist to some degree we all live
every day
absorbed in our own stories that's what
we spend most of our time thinking about
is our own stories
but when you're reading a book or
watching a film etc the beauty is that
you're becoming invested in somebody
else's story not your own
the demand that you must see yourself
reflected in it that everything must be
a mirror showing you back to yourself
ultimately defeats the purpose and only
fuels more of the narcissism that causes
this problem to begin with
it's true that we should be able to
relate to the characters and stories but
we should be able to relate to them
because of what the characters say about
the universal human condition i mean
when i read dostoevsky
for example i don't feel represented by
the characters in the way that people
mean
representation these days because the
characters are all a bunch of 19th
century russians
but i do feel represented only in the
sense
that they're dealing with moral dilemmas
and searching for deeper truths
just as i do and we all do i mean i can
relate to that because i'm a human being
that's the kind of representation that
matters but it's not the sort of
representation that we always hear about
and anyway this is all irrelevant
because it's not what's going on here
they aren't turning all the characters
gay in an effort to represent gay people
the percentage of gay and trans
characters on tv and in comics now far
exceeds the percentage in the general
population if this was truly a matter of
representation
they'd have stopped by now i mean we'd
say okay well we've got proper
representation here
it's a small minority the general
population should be a real small
minority on the screen if it's just
about representation
but it's not
because the point behind adding the gay
characters and especially making a
character like superman gay
is not to merely represent an identity
but to present an ideal
okay they're saying to the audience
especially the children in the audience
and the comic book audience is still
mostly kids
um although there are far too many
adults that
are in the audience as well
but what they're saying to the audience
is this is the ideal way to be they want
to erase straight white male characters
because the people doing the erasing
despise straight white male people
that's the point i mean you heard it
there from the guy who created the
character oh we don't want another
straight white male
saying it with with uh with disgust
so they wish to create a society
they don't want all the straight white
male people in society they want to
create a society filled with different
sorts of people
[Music]
and the so-called representation
is one way of pushing that agenda
and we know that also because it always
comes with it's not as though
okay you've made superman gay and but
then he continues along just being
superman doing superman things
and the gayness and the his his uh
his sexual attraction is just you know
it's a it's a minor detail but other
than that i mean he's fighting lex
luthor he's doing all this
that's not what they do
it comes in a package
where okay now he's focused on refugees
and he's focused on fighting climate
change and of all the villains turn into
straight white male conservatives
you know whereas that used to be the
hero now it's the villain
so it all comes in one package
and that's the point in all of these
stories
whether they're doing it in comic books
they're doing it in hollywood
on tv and media
it's about presenting an ideal to the
audience
this is how you should be
even if you can't fly around like
superman
this is the ideal way to be
and that's the point
even if of course they'll never ever be
honest about it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know as an increasing number of
companies fall all over themselves
trying to appeal to the left wouldn't it
be nice to find at least one that
supports your values well i'll give you
one charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice with five
percent of your monthly plan price and
have sent millions of dollars to
charities so far new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
when you mention offer code walsh
certain restrictions apply there charity
mobile makes it easy to switch you can
keep your existing phone number you may
even be able to keep your existing phone
as well but if you need a new phone no
problem there charity mobile has a
variety of options from basic flip
phones and low-cost smartphones to the
latest 5g phones they've got it all and
they've got monthly plan prices that uh
have were already low they've been
lowered again and now you can add even
more lines to your family plan
and you're doing all of this while also
supporting a pro-life company and
helping to build a culture of life in
america so switch to charity mobile and
support the causes you care about call
them at
or 1-877-474-3662 with them online at
charitymobile.com and mentor offer code
walsh okay so uh
great night at the ryman yesterday by
the way we did our backstage live at the
ryman which was uh pretty surreal in a
lot of ways
huge crowd there i think we were at
capacity there's 2800 people or
something like that
and uh sweet baby gang i got to tell you
sweet baby gang was there in force
people showing up in the t-shirts they
were also selling the t-shirts for fifty
seven dollars uh as well and people were
buying them it wasn't quite that much
but it was still a lot of money people
were buying the t-shirts and uh sweet
baby gang was there and i and i do you
know i feel a certain
honestly i'm wrecked with guilt today
because uh i i feel as though i did fail
the sweet baby gang because i never
gave a shout out explicitly to the sweet
baby gang
from the stage at the ryman and i wanted
to i was waiting for my opening
and it i never found the segway
and right and i realized as we were kind
of wrapping up
and jeremy was wrapping things up that
the segway wasn't going to come
and i thought now is my opportunity i
got to jump in right here at the end
i got to ruin the ending and i but i but
i didn't
at the last minute i decided not to so i
you know i take responsibility for that
i do
but still i know the sweet baby gang was
there i could feel i could feel the the
force and the energy
um
and so you know it was a lot of fun and
then we had um
you know before before the the event we
had our
vip meet and greet which was kind of a
receiving line
and i think there was 350 people in line
and you know we all took pictures with
with each person 350 people in a row
uh and i you know i have to say
i know i talk about how you know i'm an
i'm an introvert
so i don't necessarily enjoy those kinds
of i i
i don't mind being i prefer to be on
stage i don't necessarily enjoy those
kinds of interactions as much i mean
i've admitted that
but uh i thought i was being
pretty jovial
by my standards
you know i was making i had the small
talk down with each person like 350
people in a row
and so i had the brief little small talk
exchanges down we were talking about the
weather oh it's hot out there for
october what is this july am i right
you know that kind of thing and but
people kept coming up to me even still
and saying like each person that came up
would console me
saying oh this is this will be over soon
don't worry about it they were consoling
me because i was being forced to meet
them that's i thought am i really giving
off those vibes i thought i thought i'm
doing pretty well here
uh but that's just that's i guess i
can't i can't overcome that those are
that's just me that's just my
that's my aura
um and then we had and then it was also
really good
starting off the event we had the
booming let's go brandon chant
from the entire audience
um which i gotta say the l
we haven't talked about the let's go
brandon thing very much on this show
uh
i think it's a great innovation i think
it's hilarious
it's one of the most clever things i
think
that conservatives have come up with
it's a small thing but it's very clever
because of what because of what it
allows you to do because of course we
all know what we're really saying with
let's go brandon and i want to say one
other thing about that about the let's
go brandon thing
because you hear criticisms of this
even from some conservatives
who say well yeah i'm not a big fan of
let's go brandon or of the more vulgar
version of the same thing
uh you know we we shouldn't be doing
that even if we are even if we're
critics of joe biden
we shouldn't be doing that because
we should have more respect for the
office
and so at backstage last night when the
entire audience is is chanting let's go
brandon we are showing a lack of respect
for the office of the presidency
that's the criticism anyway
and uh i don't find that criticism
compelling at all i gotta tell you
and i'll tell you why because
i don't think it's our job
as citizens
to show respect for the office of the
presidency i'm not even sure exactly
what that would mean i mean what do you
mean
show respect for the office it's the is
he's the president this is not royalty
these are supposed to be public servants
they're politicians
so what exact reverence do you want for
the office itself
i think when it comes to showing respect
for the office of the presidency
that responsibility falls to the person
holding that office
they're the ones who are supposed to
show respect for it
and if and if the president the person
holding the office shows respect for the
office themselves
then i will show respect for them
okay you have to earn
if you're a politician you have to earn
the respect of the population you have
to earn the respect of the citizens
we're not going to grant it to you
just by nature the fact that you hold
the office
joe biden has shown no respect for his
own office so why should we respect it
when he abuses the powers of his office
when he stands up there and admits it
says i don't have the authority to do
this thing that i'm about to do
and then he does it
well that is showing a total lack of
respect for the office
what the office is supposed to be
for the actual responsibilities of that
office for the limits
of the power that that office grants you
so he has desecrated it
if it is a thing that could be
desecrated to begin with
he shows no respect for it
um and so i have no respect for him
i i think in in america
you know our real response when it comes
to corrupt politicians
we should treat them
with no respect at all
i think if anything there's still too
much respect
for corrupted and competent politicians
we should have zero respect for them
every single day we should get up
and say to these so-called public
servants who are supposed to be serving
us
i mean that's in theory that's what it's
supposed to be right we're supposed to
be the bosses
so we should get up every day and say to
them okay you you earn it now you want
my respect earn it
uh all right
so speaking of people who have not
earned any respect in the office that
they hold here's this from fox news that
says more than 60 concerned parents
students and residents spoke at the
loudoun county school board meeting
tuesday evening with many demanding the
resignation of loudoun county
superintendent scott ziegler in the wake
of allegations that the school district
covered up two alleged sexual assaults
parents attended the school board
meeting with signs urging ziegler to
resign
parents pointed to two alleged sexual
assaults the first of which the victim's
father claims took place on may 28th
uh this is from the daily wire report
which we which we talked about yesterday
we talked about on the backstage show as
well
the father says his ninth grade daughter
was assaulted in the bathroom by a boy
wearing a skirt elizabeth lancaster the
attorney for the father of the alleged
victim said the boy was charged with two
counts of forcible sodomy one count of
anal sodomy
and one count of forcible fellatio
the sheriff's office
says
told fox news we can confirm a may 28
2021 case that involved a thorough two
month long investigation that was
conducted to determine the facts of the
case prior to the arrest this case is
still pending court proceedings the
loudoun county sheriff's office is not
able to provide any documents that
pertain to a pending case um
at a june 22nd board meeting ziegler
declared quote that the predator
transgender student or person simply
does not exist
and that to his knowledge
we don't have any record of assaults
occurring in our restrooms
so that's what he said on june 22nd he
said there's no record of any assaults
occurring in restrooms meanwhile on may
28th there was this alleged assault
that was already making its way through
the legal system that police had been
made aware of
are we supposed to believe that ziegler
the superintendent i mean
a girl was allegedly
violently brutally raped
in a bathroom during school hours
and we're supposed to believe that
ziegler
didn't know about it
well that's impossible to believe
it's just it's impossible to believe
so we can look at this i don't think we
have to say it's an alleged cover-up by
the school board it's a cover-up
this horrible thing happened allegedly
and you denied that it happened at all
that's what a cover-up is
and we could say that even without all
the other details that we get from the
father about how when he went to the
school after this happened when they
called him to come in
and and they told him they want to keep
it in-house
even without that
you've got clear indication proof of a
cover-up when the superintendent denies
that it happened
when he had to know about it
so school board meeting was yesterday
and uh let's play this is from fox with
some of the clips here of the parents
trying to hold the school board
accountable for this um for this
cover-up let's listen
without consideration for the safety of
all students simply to satisfy a
political agenda your moral compasses
are busted
you dr ziegler and our school board
every one of you
are complicit in these crimes against
our children because you did nothing
about it
what is worse than a child being raped
at school the cover-up by those who are
entrusted with the safety and well-being
being of children warned you about
policies that you were putting into
place that would be a danger to our
students
and we've seen that happen when is
enough is enough
when are you going to change the
policies to keep our children safe
this is not china this is the united
states of america and we will not be
silenced you're liable for these
injustices remove the superintendent
immediately and then resign for your
negligence and duplicity
i am 14 years old the fact that i have
to be here to fight for my rights to not
have more radical agendas shut down from
in school is not only concerning it's
upsetting
uh the the last one there was a of
course it's hard to hear
uh exactly what's being said
and that's all by design i mean that's
why they have to wear the masks
the the masks function in in this case
as literal muzzles that's why you have
to that's why they've required them to
put them on
i mean there's there's no other audience
in the room
they're standing they're given 60
seconds to address the school board
with nobody within 15 feet of them
they can't take the mask off
they can't take it off for 60 seconds so
that they can speak and be understood
no they can't take it off because they
want the words to be muffled
these despicable gutless scumbag cowards
will do everything they possibly can
to avoid any kind of accountability
whatsoever
uh but these loudoun county parents
they they continue to put on
a clinic
for that other parents across the
country should should really follow
there's a there's a model here that's
being presented
and i obviously saw it for myself
uh when i became a resident of loudoun
county when when i was there
that they've got it organized they know
exactly what they're doing
and now because they're only given 60
seconds
to speak out about the cover-up of a
violent rape of a girl in a bathroom
during school hours
they're only given 60 seconds to talk
about it what it means is that um
you know
then you you just need you need 30 40
parents in a row hitting on this same
time because they only get 60 seconds
and if you also if you all stay on this
on the same topic and you stay on
message then
cumulatively you've you've spoken about
it for 40 minutes 50 minutes
and that's exactly what they're doing
and i hope they continue to do it
every single school board meeting
every person that goes up there
should be specifically calling for scott
ziegler
because i forget scott is his first name
anyway up for for yeah scott ziegler
to step down because of this issue until
he does
all right let's move next to uh janet
yellen treasury secretary
we have discussed the uh
proposal by the
treasury department by the bob obama the
biden administration
to monitor all bank accounts with
transactions that uh
are six hundred dollars or more so if
you
you know six hundred dollars
enters your your checking account or
leaves your checking account at any
point over the course of a year then the
irs wants to know about it and they want
to have direct access to your account so
they can monitor
all of that um
all of that information
and all that data
now janet yellen on cbs
being asked about this again and she
says no no no no this is this is not an
invasion of privacy
and if you're just a normal middle-class
person this isn't even about you
uh this is really about high income
people and billionaires
here she is explaining it
you want banks to report transactions of
600
or more that's what the irs wants
does this mean that the government is
trying to peek into our pocketbooks if
you want to look at 600 transactions
absolutely not i think this proposal has
been seriously mischaracterized
the proposal involves no reporting of
individual transactions of any
individual look the big picture is that
we have a tax gap that over the next
decade is estimated at seven trillion
dollars namely a shortfall in the amount
that irs is collecting
due to
a failure
of individuals to report the income that
they've earned but that's among
billionaires is that among people who
are transferring six hundred dollars no
it tends to be among high income
individuals whose income is opaque and
the irs doesn't receive information
about it if you earn a paycheck you get
a w-2 the irs knows about it but
high-income individuals with opaque
sources of income
that are not reported to the irs there's
a lot of tax fraud and cheating that's
going on and all that's involved in this
proposal is a few aggregate numbers
about bank accounts the amount that was
received in the course of a year the
amount that went out in the course of
the year
so am i showing um
am i failing to show respect for the
office of the treasury secretary if i
say that you know janet yellen is a
lying obfuscating clown
i don't know if that's another office
that i'm supposed to respect
the treasury secretary
she certainly doesn't have any respect
for us
and i don't i don't just mean that she
has no respect for our rights or our
privacy obviously she doesn't
um she has no respect for our
intelligence
she thinks that we're all a bunch of
you know sub 75 iq morons
that we would buy what she just said
there
so the target
allegedly is high income earners and
even billionaires
and so their their way
of of smoking out those you know those
high-income earners with obscure opaque
sources of income
is to monitor all transactions over 600
bucks
you want to find the billionaires who
are cheating on their taxes
and so you're looking at checking
accounts with 600 in them
wouldn't it be transactions over i don't
know rather than 600 dollars uh
sixty thousand dollars or at least six
thousand dollars
something
exponentially greater than six hundred
so you're looking for a very specific
small sliver
of um
of people here
you're you're fishing for a very
particular allegedly a very particular
kind of fish
and your way of doing that
is to cast this massive net
that'll catch
dozens of species of fish that you
aren't even looking for
that's
it's almost believable in a certain way
because it's so
boneheaded and inefficient
and wasteful that yeah it's exactly what
you expect from the government
they're looking for billionaires and so
they start with people
who spend 600 in a month
uh
it's such a it's such a dumb claim that
you you could almost believe that they
would be this stupid but um no i don't
think it's it's it's their own stupidity
i think it's their assumption about our
stupidity that we would believe that
now this as i said is about what this is
really about is putting
everybody under a permanent financial
you know
under a permanent irs audit
they are auditing almost all americans
i don't know what percentage and if i
would that'd be an interesting thing i
wish they could tell us that what
percentage of americans have
transactions in a given month totaling
at least over six hundred dollars
like you know i gotta think it's a
pretty sizable majority
so a sizable majority of americans are
having their
economic freedom and privacy erased
and were all being put under a permanent
audit
so that
they don't have to go through the
trouble
of having individual specific audits of
the actual people that they are
trying to find
attach
the billionaire tax cheats and so on
all right next this is from the daily
wire says the chicago police department
is engaged in a nationwide campaign to
recruit police officers but the city is
still suffering from an officer shortage
with officers retiring and transferring
to smaller departments chicago appears
to be down nearly 1600 officers
the city's cbs affiliate reported on
tuesday that chicago police officers
aren't only retiring in record numbers
many are leaving the big city
departments for smaller ones
it's contributing to an officer shortage
that many city leaders believe will only
get worse before it gets better
officers who spoke to cbs chicago noted
that the problems go beyond simple
burnout though that's a contributing
factor to many officers decision to
leave the department officers cited long
working hours mandatory overtime and low
pay as reasons they departed chicago for
other cities or decided to simply leave
the force entirely
i
honestly if you value your your life and
the lives of your
children and your family
i don't know how you remain living in a
place like chicago
and i understand that it's a lot easier
said than done and someone who doesn't
live in chicago myself and i don't
depend
i don't have a job that requires me to
be there i understand that
i also understand that moving is
difficult
since i've been married we've moved
like six times
but the point is it can be done
i just don't understand how anyone
who has any other options stays there
in chicago or in cities like it
they're running out of cops
and
meanwhile they've
decriminalized gang shootings in that
city it was just last week that they
they decided not to file any charges
against gang members who shot and killed
each other in the middle of the street
it's it's not going to get better
you've seen this precipitous decline and
uh you'll you'll notice it it there's
there has not been an uptick
it hasn't been
we haven't seen any evidence that the
trends are going to start heading in a
positive direction and they won't
because all of this stuff has a snowball
effect
um and here's here's the problem and you
find this in chicago and it's not just
in chicago where they're having trouble
attracting police officers recruiting
and hiring police officers they're
they're having trouble keeping cops
um
on the job
even the ones that have already been
hired
it it's it's
that's obviously no mystery
i mean it's
it has been turned into an almost
impossible job to be a police officer
and cops now know
in this case this again is the case not
just in chicago but across the entire
country
you know you go out and you do your job
on a daily basis
it's bad enough knowing that
the media is completely against you
much of the community
that you're risking your life to protect
they also hate your guts
and you know
that the moment
you're trying to arrest someone for
committing a crime
the moment they start resisting
the moment they turn violent
the moment they grab a gun and start
shooting at you
it's a lose-lose situation
and the more violent they are towards
you the more of a loser situation it is
because you could
not respond with uh equal force and end
up getting killed
or you can respond with equal force
and neutralize
the dangerous threat
and then you know that the media and
the community that you were just
protecting and serving there will
immediately set to work to destroy your
life because of it
so that's what you know as a cop the
moment the bad guy pulls out a knife or
a gun in that moment you know okay um
good chance here i'm either dead at the
end of this or in prison no matter how
it goes
what what a mystery that's
people aren't very eager to sign up for
something like that
and here's what here's what ends up
happening i mean you've obviously got
lots of cops that leave
what about the cops that
stay on the job
or the ones who actually still sign up
for this job
despite this
this kind of environment this kind of
atmosphere
what kind of people are you going to
attract now
well the only people that right now that
i could see that would sign up to be a
cop i think there's probably like two
types of people
one would be
people who have a deep sense of duty
and are extremely courageous
and they feel called to this and they're
gonna do it anyway
knowing what a lose-lose it might be for
them
knowing they're putting their life on
the line
in more ways than one
because their physical lives could be
taken from them
or everything but their physical lives
could be taken from them if they have to
you know use force against the violent
suspect and then their lives are
destroyed
you know knowing all of that they still
sign up for it i think there are going
to be people who do it because because
they just they they feel duty-bound
and these are courageous
self-sacrificing people
but that's not gonna be everybody
um you're also gonna have people who
sign up for it because
they're just desperate for a job
i suppose you have some people like that
um
but a lot of the people who are in
between who maybe are not
heroes but aren't villains either just
kind of like normal people
who in previous years may have become
police officers
they're gonna have no interest
we've scared all of them away
and as i said it's not gonna get any
better from here
uh finally this is from the daily wire
it says
lego group is committed to uh removing
gender bias and harmful stereotypes from
its toys the company announced in a
statement on monday lego cited a study
by the gina davis institute on gender in
media
a non-profit pushing for gender balance
and entertainment and media showing the
majority of children believe that some
activities are just meant for girls
while others are meant for boys
lego is calling on parents and children
to champion inclusive play to change the
perception of children according to the
toy company
and this is happening at the same time
that the california governor gavin
newsom
signed a law
mandating in the entire state of
california that large retail stores have
to offer
toys in gender-neutral sections so if
they
if they employ 500 or more employees
across california um it is now a matter
of law that they have to have a
gender-neutral section
for toys which of course that doesn't
achieve anything but just make it harder
for parents
who are shopping
you know trying to find toys for their
for their kids
because
all parents realize this like the vast
majority of kids
it's not because we tell boys oh here
are the here are the toys for boys you
have to play with those
oh you're a girl where you're you're
only allowed to have pink things and you
have to play with dolls
we don't tell our kids that it's just
that that's most of the time what they
naturally gravitate to from a very young
age
and it's it's always been an interesting
thing for me to have
you know i've kind of had this uh
been able to see this this this play out
in my own life having
a boy you know having fraternal twins
boy and a girl
and
raising them you know they were the
first kids that we had and uh we raised
them the same way and we had you know we
have a
even from uh from a young age we had a
play room and with all the toys laid out
and we we never said to our daughter
well here's the girl section of toys
here's the boys section
and you got to stay over here we never
said that we just here's the toys go
play
get out of mom and dad's hair for a
second and go play with the toys and
what would they do
almost every time
daughter's going for the dolls the sun's
going for the action figures
because it turns out that there is
something innate within you know there's
something about girls from a young age
where they have this kind of maternal
instinct and that's why they like to
play with the dolls and they'll sit
there and brush the doll's hair and
they'll they have fun changing the dolls
diapers boys for them for the most part
don't do that
there's something innate and ingrained
most parents recognize this
some parents recognize it to their heart
because they wish they don't want their
kid to subscribe to these genders awful
gender stereotypes and yet they do
and so you get rid of the
gender segregation of the of the toy
department all you're doing is just
making it hard for the parents because
they because they're still looking for
the same kinds of toys
i think it was target did this a while
ago where they made a big deal about oh
we're not gonna we're not gonna separate
toys by boy versus girl anymore
but if you go to target still and you go
to the toy section they've still done
that i mean they've got all of the girl
type toys here and this aisle and all
the boy type toys here they just don't
have the word boy and girl on it
and almost every parent who has a
daughter they're going to the girls
section
because this stuff is much of it is
innate
it is not determined by society
despite what we're told
all right let's get now to reading the
comments
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
tiffany says matt quoting the princess
bride earned himself for the spot of
best youtuber in my book well it sounds
like you got pretty low standards but
i'll take it and uh yeah i'm an
unapologetic fan of the princess bride i
i think it's it's
you can't call it one of the greatest
films ever made certainly but it's one
of the most rewatchable
movies i think
ever made it's one of those movies that
anytime it's on tv you could just sit
down and watch it and enjoy it
um
and all right what else we got here
uh
mr walsh of all the different names of
christ do you have a personal favorite
also what's the most important thing
you've learned since you started your
show and have seen it grow like it has
uh personal favorite name of christ well
i think christ
is
that's a good one i'm happy with that
our lord i suppose is also i hadn't
really thought about what my favorite
name is as far as what i've i've learned
since starting the show i'm not sure if
uh if this is something i've learned but
i've just seen it i've seen it
demonstrated over and over again and
that is that um
people are
desperate
for
basic common sense
and uh
that's a bad sign for society
that common sense is so rare
but it has made it possible it's given
me a career
because there's there's so much insanity
out there all you have to do is speak
basic truths
you don't have to have any deeper
brilliant insights and that's good
because i don't have any all i could
just do then i could sit here and say uh
you know
women have uteruses
and even a truth like that people are
hungry and desperate for it so i guess
that's i suppose what i learned scott
says ben used your office today but the
alien playing the banjo and the little
astronaut on your desk weren't visible
on the camera
um i'm afraid he stole them
you know they do that sometimes they
come in here they kick me out of my own
studio
i mean ben comes in here like he owns
the place or something tells me to leave
and every time that happens no matter
who's using the studio
they they always take the alien in the
banjo away
it's like fine you can use my studio if
you want
but you this is this is my studio
don't don't
there's nothing to be ashamed of with
the alien and the banjo
i do take offense to that
uh tom says hey matt you silly person
people sleep uh
people sleep you're counting that as
free time i wake two hours before work
one hour is just to get there when you
add that in my work day is 11 hours so i
only have five hours of free time
okay so you have five hours of free time
and you get eight hours of sleep a night
and then you have your weekends off
that's that's amazing
that that's a great life
i mean that that's that's a more that's
the point i was making yesterday that
that is already a more luxurious and
comfortable life you are leading already
a more luxurious and comfortable life
than the vast majority of people who
have ever lived on earth
so so have some gratitude for that now a
word from helix sleep a lot of people
these days seem to struggle um with
sleeplessness it seems to be an
increasing problem i know you know it is
for me especially last night i think i
got about three hours of sleep but that
was not the fault of my helix matrix
mattress uh in helix sleep because helix
sleep
is uh it's the most comfortable mattress
you'll ever sleep on
and the reason is that it's customized
to you all you got to do is take the
quiz takes about two minutes to complete
and it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back whatever it is you go
through all of it like i said take just
two minutes
and they'll find the specific mattress
that will work with your unique taste
you don't need to take their word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine and you can find out
why yourself go to helixsleep.com walsh
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life right now helix is
offering up to 200 off and free pillows
with all mattress orders for our
listeners at helix sleep dot com slash
walsh that's helix sleep dot com slash
waltz for up to 200 off your mattress
order and if you didn't catch backstage
last night then you missed a lot of
things especially the melodic
uh sounds of smoky mike and the god king
uh and so
that was already that was already your
biggest mistake was to miss out on that
but even worse it means you didn't hear
the extremely exciting news we've got
several new projects in the works that
are going to change the way you stream
because here at daily wire we recognize
the important role entertainment plays
in our culture and in our world and
we've been working overtime
to make sure we're bringing you non-woke
content that you literally won't find
anywhere else like our new comedy series
we're bringing you featuring none other
none other than the hilarious adam
corolla and our new film starring the
fearless gina carano it's called terror
on the prairie which is currently in
production in montana and last but
definitely not least we're dropping the
teaser trailer for shut-in our first
original production it's a 60-second
look into a thriller that you're not
going to want to miss we seriously can't
wait to share the final products with
you so keep your ears and eyes peeled
for updates on their release dates now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know we followed the uh john gruden
story pretty closely on the show because
i believe it's not only one of the most
egregious examples of cancer culture
that we've ever witnessed but also
because it represents in many ways
a dangerous escalation we've seen people
get cancelled for opinions they've
expressed in public we've seen them get
canceled after statements they made or
things they posted years ago were
dredged up and brought to the surface
we've seen conversations taken out of
context
we've seen jokes blown out of proportion
we've seen innocuous comments turned
into outrages and edgy comments turned
into hate crimes
in the case of john gruden all these
things are happening at once with the
added indignity that nothing he said was
public he communicated his thoughts and
private emails from a private email
account
but that didn't save him from the mob
and the mob wants us to know that
it's not going to save us either
because every cancellation is
performative it's never about the
present victim
but about setting the stage for the next
one
and that's why this story matters and
why i want to focus on it one more time
here of course you know as we've seen
the media especially the sports media
has been enjoying itself immensely with
this issue as they always do when
they've got someone to cancel they enjoy
it very much all the various hosts and
personalities
in sports media have taken the
opportunity to give their own little
speeches have their own theatrically
emotional moments none of them can top
randy moss's oscar-worthy performance
um but you know they're all giving it a
shot there's no point in playing many of
the examples but a few of them are
instructive because of what they reveal
about the nature of cancel culture and
what fuels it
so we'll play clips from two
commentators first here's keyshawn
johnson he's the former nfl wide
receiver
and a current espn analyst he has known
gruden for a long time decades
and played for him back in the early
2000s
now that gruden is on the floor johnson
is happy to come on over and stomp on
his head because why not let's listen
i didn't know that that john would
say things like that and and put him in
an email
he just always
been
a fraud to me
he just always been a fraud to me never
never from day one
he's been a used car salesman and
people bought it
because
he inherited a championship team built
by tony dungy and rich mckay and he came
in there with a little bit of different
energy that we had with tony and it kind
of kicked us over the top to get our
world championship which i am grateful
for
but at the same time i also saw through
who he was
through that journey of getting a
championship
the year that we think about it
we won the championship and we're
standing on the podium in the super bowl
and the general manager is trying to
raise the trophy and the hair coach
takes the trophy from him
basically says give me this this belongs
to me
and like
all of that when you're paying attention
and then the next year the general
manager leaves in the middle of the
season
because he doesn't want to deal with
all the shenanigans that was going on he
lead think about this though jay
and max he leaves in the middle rich
mckay
left in the middle of the season to go
take another job with another team
because he didn't want to be around this
guy
so it just shows how one of the things
that keeps cancer culture alive and
thriving in our culture is the
corresponding death of loyalty i mean
the canceled person
cannot rely on the people who know him
to speak up for him instead they'll
remain silent or else they'll come out
as johnson does here and say oh yeah
that guy total jerk never mentioned it
before right now but now that you
mention it yeah you know i've always
hated him a lot of these situations
could be solved i mean cancer culture
could be stopped in its tracks if the
friends employers associates
of the canceled person were willing to
venture even an inch out onto the limb
to speak up for the victim but
loyalty is a virtue and we live in a
virtuous culture think of chris harrison
former bachelor host uh you know who of
course was canceled and his his own
girlfriend came out
and called him a racist when he was
getting all the backlash
now next and finally we have emmanuel
acho a former player to our media
personality turned unapologetic scumbag
race baiter here he is giving his
thoughts on the matter and pay attention
to what he says because um
these people just are not hiding the
real goal anymore listen to this
couple quick thoughts on john gruden and
boy i got a lot of them first things
first get them the heck up out of there
man no place in our society for language
like that for speech like that for
thoughts like that particularly
for people in positions of power not in
sports or in life now for those saying
it was in 2011 it was such a long time
ago
keep in mind he was 48 years old in 2011
but more importantly the dude said he
didn't have a blade of racism in him
while being racist which means he didn't
even realize what he was doing was wrong
so he hasn't worked to fix it so those
thoughts john gruden had in 2011 if he
ain't work to fix him he still has him
now but y'all this is why it's
imperative to have minorities as voices
and faces in positions of power and
society so you don't have rampant
ignorance running around like this the
dude was homophobic the dude was
racially insensitive the dude was
sending topless photos of washington
cheerleaders to the president of the
washington football team
make it make sense and lastly dude ain't
even a good coach right now he's 67 and
82 since he won the super bowl that's a
45 winning percentage he gotta go period
no place in our society for language
like that says the man who i'm sure has
never uttered a crass word in his entire
life but more notably he says there's no
place in our society for thoughts like
that
so they're no longer even pretending
that their goal is to stop people from
engaging in harmful behavior
they're not pretending that this is
about holding people accountable for the
damage they inflict on other people
this is about telling people what kind
of thoughts they're allowed to think
as acha said to don lemon later in the
day it doesn't even matter how you
actually treat people all that matters
is what you're thinking while you do it
listen
just because someone treats you right
does not mean that they treat everybody
right john gruden of course he treated
historic quarterback earning 125 million
dollars of course he treated him with
the utmost respect particularly publicly
but just because someone is kind and
respectful to you does not mean that
they are a kind and respectful person
actually if someone treats you well and
you've never been presented any evidence
that he treats anyone else differently
um
that is you know if all you've ever seen
from someone is kind and respectful
behavior that's all you've ever seen
and no one's ever told you about
different experiences
then you have no right to any assumption
other than the assumption that the
person is kind and respectful
see in a sane society you judge a man
based on his actions
and in fact if someone has negative
feelings or thoughts
towards you or in general
and yet still treats you well
um that doesn't make him a fraud far
from it it makes him all the more
respectable because he's not allowing
his emotions
to dictate his behavior
but these days as we've seen actions
don't matter
and again
it's not about actions here because
these are private emails
no one was harmed by them no one else
knew about them
so it's a victimless crime until
they're made public
it wasn't john gruden who decided to do
that
so the point here is about the thoughts
about the feelings
and what we know from the mob is that
all that really matters
is what they assume your feelings or
thoughts really are
and they can assume what your real
intentions are
and that's what they're trying to
control are the thoughts
this is about drawing a line and saying
okay here are thoughts you're allowed to
think
and hear thoughts you're not allowed to
think
but of course i say all this and now my
my third day of talking about this issue
because i do think it's important
but the problem is that this all sounds
like a defense
of john gruden which it isn't
because you know my policy
that if you if you don't defend yourself
if you apologize
then i'm not going to defend you
the moment you do that
you accept guilt
you bow to the mob
there's nothing anyone else can do for
you
and so really at the at the end of all
this i guess i have to say that um
maybe it's john gruden who is cancelled
not not for not for any emails that he
sent i don't care about that
but when you have the mob coming after
you
and you bow and surrender and submit
then you've only fueled it
you've only you've only this this is
what sustains them you've given the more
the more sustenance
to go after the next person
at a at a certain point i mean we need
someone we just need someone i'm not
surprised that it's not john gruden but
maybe it'll be the next one whoever it
is and it'll be someone
they'll find a new target they'll find
them quick
they got what they want out of this they
destroyed his life they got the apology
but they're not waiting around to have a
conversation about it
what have you learned from this john how
you know how can we how can we help you
get back on your feet and you know how
can we work on this redemption arc they
don't care about that
they're just going to leave you in
tatters
torn to shreds on the side of the road
and they're going gonna go looking for
the next person to run over
we just finally need someone when this
happens
to say
i i don't apologize
oh but you hurt our feelings yeah i
don't care
and i didn't even really hurt your
feelings in the first place but even if
i did i don't care
i don't owe you anything
this isn't about you
this doesn't concern you
mind your damned business
get out of my face
and until they say that until someone
says that this will uh this will
continue
so
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
superman gets a little light in the
loafers the italian people chant let's
go a brandon or actually a little bit of
a tougher variation thereof on the
streets of rome and rolling stone
magazine attacks a rock and roll legend
for not blindly going along with
authority check it out on the michael
knowles show